[ENERGETIC MUSIC]
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
And welcome to episode 119
of the weekly "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague as always,
Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
doing good, Mark.
How are you?
And we have a special
co-host with us today.
MARK MANDEL: We do have a very
special co-host with us today.
Sherol, how are you doing today?
SHEROL CHEN: I'm doing great.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
We are talking to
NVIDIA today, which
is actually a really interesting
discussion on our interview.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
We're going to be
getting into more
of the details around GPUs
and AI in our interview
later on with Bryan.
But before we do
that, as always,
we go into the cool
things of the week.
And we have a
question of the week.
And this week's question,
we're going to--
and this is part of the reason
why Sherol's joining us today.
We want to talk about GDC, the
Game Developers Conference,
that is going on as we speak,
and that you and Sherol will
be attending.
So we want to talk about what
you guys find is exciting,
and as veterans of
GDC, what do you all
recommend to those who
might be new or exploring it
for the first time.
But first, as always, we like
to get into our cool things
of the week.
And one of the cool
things of the week
is that we have the V100s,
which is the NVIDIA GPU.
And that is coming
to Google Cloud.
That will be available in all
the Clouds, all the Google
Clouds.
MARK MANDEL: All
the Google Clouds.
MELANIE WARRICK: All
There's a lot of Google Clouds.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That's a lot of Clouds.
MELANIE WARRICK:
There's a lot of Clouds.
MARK MANDEL: They have
lot of regions now.
Awesome.
I want to have a quick plug
for a blog post written
by one of our fellow
DevRel members,
Chris Broadfoot, here
in San Francisco,
also a fellow Australian
and guest on the podcast
previously.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
He wrote a blog post talking
about automatic serverless
deployments with Google Cloud
Repositories and Container
Builder.
He has a great blog
post talking through how
you can build CI and
CD pipelines using
Cloud Functions, Source
Repositories, Container
Builder.
It's actually really easy to do.
I've done it for the CI
pipeline for [INAUDIBLE] It's
actually kind of
cool how much you
can get done with just
a few bits of JavaScript
and some Cloud Builder scripts.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And Sherol, did you have
something you wanted to share?
SHEROL CHEN: Oh, yeah.
Two of the projects
on the Magenta team
have had a launch
this past week.
It's been really
exciting, a lot of fun.
It's interesting, because
one is on the research
side of the machine
learning and creativity,
and then the second one
is on the productization
of creative machine--
like machine
learning for creativity.
For the research side,
we have MusicVAE.
And on the product side,
we have NSynth Super,
which is an open source
piece of hardware that
runs machine learning models
to generate sounds for music.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We'll have to dive
into more detail in a
later, I think, podcast.
MARK MANDEL: I think we might
have to do a Magenta episode.
I think that might be--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, I think we will.
MARK MANDEL: --something
we need to do.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
so the last thing
we wanted to mention
for this week, in terms
of cool things of the
week, is that there's
this great article out
there on the building
blocks of interpretability.
And we'll share a link in
the show notes as always.
What this article goes over
is the different techniques
and approaches that have
been used and explored
for interpretability
for machine learning,
especially neural nets,
like feature visualization,
attribution,
dimensionality reduction.
But it's looking
at it and trying
to take those approaches
as building blocks
and combine them.
And that's what's unique in
this article in particular.
And it's trying to do it in
a way that's human-scale,
as it says, something that's
understandable by humans.
So we'll share that.
It's interesting.
And yeah, I think that covers
us for cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with our buddy over
at NVIDIA.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
So on this week's
podcast, we are
excited to have join
us Bryan Catanzaro, who
is the VP of Applied Deep
Learning Research at NVIDIA.
BRYAN CATANZARO: Hey.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good afternoon.
And so, Bryan, can you tell
us a little about yourself
and the work that
you're doing now,
and the work you've
done in the past?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Sure.
So I lead a team of
researchers here at NVIDIA
that's focused on using
deep learning to make
NVIDIA's products better and
NVIDIA's processes better.
And so we're looking at
a bunch of different ways
of using AI in lots
of different domains,
ranging from video games to chip
design, and all sorts of stuff
in between.
So it's an exciting time to
be working in AI applications.
There's a lot of diamonds
on the beach waiting
for people to pick
them up and change
the way that we do things.
And so it's a pretty
exciting project.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
And in terms of NVIDIA, I
know NVIDIA has lead the way
when it comes to GPUs.
And GPUs have played
such a significant role
in the deep learning space,
as well as the gaming space.
We were talking
about this, actually,
right before we
started the podcast,
but how impressive it is that
NVIDIA's strategy around GPUs
in particular has shifted
over the last few years alone.
And can you speak to
that a little bit?
BRYAN CATANZARO: You know,
I think NVIDIA has always
had a strong belief that
GPUs, as a throughput-oriented
processor, were going to
change the world beyond gaming.
And more than 10
years ago, NVIDIA
started investing in CUDA,
which is our language
and sort of ecosystem
for programming
throughput-oriented computers.
And at the beginning, we were
a little bit less certain
about what applications were
going to need this power,
and what was actually going
to change in the world.
Because we had this new way
of thinking about algorithms
and computation.
But I think the belief
has been consistent.
And the focus has been
there for a long time.
Deep learning happened
to be the most important
of all of the applications
that need high throughput
computation.
And so once NVIDIA saw that,
it was basically instant.
The whole company
latched onto it,
because they realized
this is our chance
to make a difference.
And I happened to be involved
in that a little bit.
I was one of the
very first people
working on deep learning back
at NVIDIA Research back in 2012.
And we were having fun and
doing this research project.
And like many research
projects, it wasn't clear to me
at the time whether this was
going to be something fun,
or whether this was
going to be something
that really changed the world.
But the amount of interest in
our work was really surprising.
The results were
good, and people
started paying a lot
of attention to it.
And I started meeting with a lot
of different people at NVIDIA.
And they kind of saw--
the whole company kind
of saw-- like, wow,
this could be really big for us.
And so everybody
latched onto it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do you
remember a specific time
when you were doing that
research that stood out
to you, that made you go,
oh, wow, this is much more
impactful than I expected?
Or a specific moment
that comes to mind?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So one of the things that
attracted some attention,
we published a paper
at ICML in 2013.
And this was me collaborating
with a group of researchers
at Stanford, including
Adam Coates and Andrew Ng.
We were able to take an approach
to unsupervised learning
that was pioneered, actually,
in the Google Brain team
by Quoc Le, and we were able
to replicate that using far,
far fewer computers.
So Quoc had published
this paper in 2012.
And he needed something
like 1,000 nodes
in order to train this model.
And we were able to train the
model with three nodes using
GPUs and more efficient software
that was kind of a little bit
more HPC-focused.
And so we published
this paper at ICML.
And people were like, wow,
this is really exciting,
because it
democratizes the work.
If it makes deep
learning a thing
that you can do on three
nodes instead of 1,000,
then the number
of people that can
start applying this
technology to new problems
just goes up dramatically.
And that, that was something
that caught a lot of attention.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And just to confirm,
when you're talking about
what you were working on,
this is cuDNN.
BRYAN CATANZARO: So this was
actually before cuDNN existed.
So I did this with
Adam and Andrew.
And that was really exciting.
And I started talking to more
deep learning researchers.
And actually, the person that
inspired me to make cuDNN
was Rob Fergus, who was
a professor at New York
University, one of Yann
LeCun's collaborators.
And I think Rob is
now at Facebook.
And Rob was like,
look, we are doing
all these convolutional
models all the time.
And we've written
our own convolutions,
but we think it's a lot
of work to make them fast.
And NVIDIA GPUs change all
the time, because that's
the primary way
NVIDIA innovates,
is by making the
architecture better.
But then that means
that the software
needs to adapt to
the new architecture.
And so, Rob was
telling me, we're
spending too much time
working on these kernels.
We think NVIDIA should
make a library for it.
And I thought, yeah,
that's a great idea.
So then I set about
convincing the rest of NVIDIA
that they should
make this product.
And it took a
little bit of work.
So while I was
convincing them, I just
started writing the code
for a research prototype.
And then as the
conversations progressed,
things got more concrete.
And then finally, people
kind of caught the vision
and decided, yes, we
should productize this.
And that became cuDNN.
MARK MANDEL: So this
sounds really cool.
I know, as we've said
before on the podcast,
Melanie's the MLs expert.
And I'm sort of the person--
MELANIE WARRICK: You're
the gaming expert.
MARK MANDEL: --who
barely understands math.
For those people who aren't as
familiar with this ecosystem,
and maybe you are more
like, doesn't NVIDIA
make gaming cards, first of--
BRYAN CATANZARO: We do.
MARK MANDEL: But how does
that translate to doing--
what is that pathway from,
I have a graphics card.
I thought it was
just for graphics.
Why is it also applicable,
or how is it also applicable,
to doing what seems to
be intense mathematical
calculations?
BRYAN CATANZARO: When you
draw a picture in a 3D game,
you're essentially running a
lot of programs that figure out
what every pixel looks like.
And over the years,
those programs
have gotten more complex,
as you might expect,
and also a lot more flexible.
It used to be that GPUs were
very fixed-function machines,
where you kind of just
gave it a list of triangles
and it rasterized them.
But nowadays, to do the
complex lighting and texturing
and reflections, and
so forth, all that
is done by writing programs,
but very parallel programs.
And so it turns out,
actually, that the workload
in modern games often is--
majority of the time is being
spent running compute programs
rather than running
traditional graphics workloads.
And so there has
been an evolution
in graphics towards more
flexibility and more
parallel computing, and less
fixed-function graphics.
And so GPUs have had to
evolve to support that.
At the same time, if you have a
really high throughput parallel
processor that can be used
for arbitrary computation,
it turns out there's a lot of
things that you can do with it,
including AI.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, and I'm curious,
how did you even get involved
with parallel processing
compute?
What inspired you to go down
this path to begin with?
BRYAN CATANZARO: When
I was an undergrad,
I did some internships at Intel.
And I was working
on circuit design.
And I made some really,
really fast circuits
that were going to run
at like 10 gigahertz.
And this was for
transistors that hadn't even
been built yet.
So we were kind of
dreaming about the future
and trying to build it.
And we kept figuring out that
the power consumption was
going to be impossible.
There was just no
way that we were
going to be able to make a
single-threaded computer that
held onto the performance
scaling trends
that everyone expected.
So I saw at Intel
this realization
that the world of
computing and the future
must become parallel.
And so when I went
to graduate school,
I decided to focus on
parallel computing, frameworks
for programming
parallel computers,
and applications of
parallel computers.
And the one that really
struck me as most promising
was machine learning.
And so, that's how I ended up
spending my PhD on programming
frameworks for parallel
processors and machine learning
applications.
Because I felt like that
was the most important thing
you can do with a
parallel computer.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And then I know, in terms of
your background, you were here,
you were working on cuDNN.
And then you made a shift,
and you joined Baidu.
BRYAN CATANZARO: I did.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you were
on machine learning with Baidu.
And then you've come back.
BRYAN CATANZARO: That's right.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's
led to that trajectory?
BRYAN CATANZARO:
Well, so, I mentioned
before that my introduction
to the world of deep learning
happened with Andrew
Ng and Adam Coates.
They founded this lab at Baidu,
the Silicon Valley AI lab,
and asked me to come join them.
And I felt like it was a
great opportunity for me
to get closer to applications.
I really loved working on cuDNN.
I'm very proud of it.
And I felt like I wanted to
be a little bit closer to how
we take AI and make it into
something that solves a problem
that people really
need to be solved.
And so I felt like working
with the Silicon Valley AI
lab at Baidu gave
me a great chance
to get closer to applications.
And then I'd been there
for about 2 and 1/2 years,
and I felt like I
had accomplished
my mission, was looking
around to figure out
what my next project should be.
And Jensen Huang, NVIDIA'S CEO,
called me up and said, hey,
we'd really like you
to come back to NVIDIA
and found a lab focused
on research figuring out
how to apply AI to problems
that we have at NVIDIA.
And I thought,
well, that's great.
Because I love NVIDIA.
I've always been sort
of an ally of NVIDIA.
Because I believe
in the technology.
And a chance to come back
and focus on the applications
that I really wanted
to do, it seemed
like a great opportunity.
MELANIE WARRICK: What kind of
application do you work on?
BRYAN CATANZARO: So my
team right now is mostly
focused on three areas.
One of them is graphics.
One of them is text.
And the other is audio.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
BRYAN CATANZARO:
So with graphics,
we're really excited
about the opportunities
to change the way that graphics
is created and rendered
by using deep learning.
We have a paper, actually,
in this year's CVPR
that is about a generative
model for creating graphics--
photo-realistic,
high-resolution graphics--
given very simplistic
input images.
And so the idea would
be that we could create
a new kind of graphics engine,
where the traditional graphics
is actually doing very
little work at all,
and the majority of
the graphics rendering
is being done by a
generative model.
And the advantage
of doing that would
be that we believe it will
be far cheaper to create
virtual worlds.
Because in order to
create a new world,
we just need to
train a new model
rather than spend a lot of money
with an army of artists that
can manually create
all the textures
and lighting that go
into that environment.
So we're pretty
excited about that.
And we feel like there
is a lot of applications
for AI in graphics.
And so that's one of the
things going on in my group.
We're also working on
some text problems.
We're really inspired
by this OpenAI paper,
doing unsupervised learning
for text classifications,
specifically sentiment
analysis, where
you train a model to reconstruct
a large text database
character by character.
And it turns out
that in so doing,
your model has to understand
the meaning of the text,
not just the characters
and the text.
And you can use that with
just a little bit of labels
to solve some really
applied problems,
like sentiment analysis.
And so we're working
on stuff like that.
And then in the audio
space, right now
we're working on some things
related to speech and speech
synthesis.
MELANIE WARRICK: So in terms
of doing this type of work,
you're trying to also set it up
to make it accessible to users
of the GPUs, I assume.
BRYAN CATANZARO: Absolutely.
Yeah.
One of the great things
about working at NVIDIA
is that we get to open
source a lot of the work
that we're doing.
In fact, all of the projects
that I'm mentioning,
we have either open
sourced or we're
in the process of open sourcing.
And one of the reasons
that we can do that
is because the more we
inspire other people to do AI,
then the better
it is for NVIDIA.
Because so much of
AI happens on GPUs.
And so we can make the
world a better place
by giving people new
technology that they
can use to solve problems.
And it also helps
NVIDIA's business.
And so it's a great thing for
us to open source our work.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
And then, I know you've done
the work in the past on cuDNN,
and really driving
software to help people
optimize working on GPUs.
But then there's GPUs
that have been actually
built, specifically Volta,
to help with deep learning.
Can you speak to
you a little bit
about Volta, and how
it works and helps
people improve their
processing of deep learning?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Yeah.
So, Volta is the
first GPU that NVIDIA
made after it woke up to the
possibilities of deep learning.
And NVIDIA believes,
I think more strongly
than any other organization
that I've seen,
in the power of
specialized architecture.
That's really what
has made NVIDIA
successful from the beginning,
is the company builds chips
to solve important problems,
and that are tailored
to those particular problems.
So when NVIDIA
decided, deep learning
is the most important
thing that we're
going to be using our
GPUs for, the next step
was to customize the
architecture for deep learning.
And Volta is the first
fruits of that effort.
And so, the computational
capabilities of Volta
are really astounding.
One Volta GPU can run
at over 120 teraflops
when you're training a model.
And that's about 10 times
faster than the speed
that you would get on
our prior generation GPU.
And so that's a really
exciting capability.
MARK MANDEL: How
does the architecture
for something like Volta differ
from something like a graphics
GPU?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Volta
is different in a lot
of ways from our previous GPUs.
It's just a lot more focused
on compute workloads.
So especially the
memory subsystem
has been beefed up to handle
the kinds of data patterns
that are required in a
lot of compute workloads.
It also has a lot faster
integer arithmetic,
which is really useful for
addressing math and more,
I would say,
complicated workloads
where you need to do
a lot of indexing math
to figure out what data you're
going to load and operate on.
So the whole architecture
has been revamped.
And then, in addition to
all those other features,
we added Tensor Cores,
which are essentially
matrix multiply units that
can do small matrix, 4 by 4
by 4, matrix multiplications.
And the thing that's really
great about Tensor Cores
is that they dramatically
reduce the energy
cost of reading and writing
the operands from the register
file.
Because the majority of the work
happens inside of this bigger,
chunkier unit, and you
don't have to be constantly
reading and writing all of
the intermediate results
to register file.
And so that dramatically
reduces the energy
that's required to do a
matrix multiplication, which
then makes the processor
dramatically more efficient.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
So, you mentioned
about teraflops.
Can you help-- for those who
might not understand teraflops,
exaflops-- explain a
little bit more, I guess,
in layman's terms
what that means,
and what they can
really conceptualize
in terms of speed?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Yeah.
Well, it's hard,
actually, for humans
to understand these numbers.
Because they're
really big numbers.
But tera is 10 to 12th.
So 120 teraflops, that's
120 trillion math operations
per second, which is a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
That is a lot.
BRYAN CATANZARO: And training
a deep learning model
can often require exaflops.
So, after tera comes peta.
So, that's 10 to the 15th.
And after peta comes
exa, which is 10 to 18th.
And so training a
deep learning model
routinely takes
tens of exaflops.
I like to point out
that people often
estimate the number of grains
of sand on planet Earth
at about 10 exagrains of sand.
So if you're doing 10 exaflops,
it's kind of like a multiply
or an add for every
single grain of sand.
And you do that every
time you train a model.
So it's extremely
computationally intense.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
it turns it around.
I mean, the speed at
which it can turn around
some of these models that are
becoming larger and larger,
and have more data that
they're trying to process, is--
it has its impact.
It's very important
at the end of the day.
BRYAN CATANZARO: It is.
Yeah.
I mean, when you're trying
to solve a problem with AI,
you have to iterate.
Because it's a search.
You have to find
the right model.
You have to find the
right hyperparameters.
You have to find the right data.
And that requires
a lot of search.
And so, as you create a
model, and you train it,
you learn things about it.
You learn when it is doing well.
You learn when it's
not doing well.
You find bugs.
You fix hyperparameters.
This requires training the
model many, many times.
And the quicker you can do
it, the faster a developer
can iterate, and that
leads to better results.
And so people find
that having access
to this kind of
compute capability,
it not just makes
the work go faster,
but it actually changes
the kind of problems
that they can attempt.
Because there's problems
that they can try that
they just never would have
been able to try without it.
MELANIE WARRICK: And when
you talk about training,
there's training, and
there's also inference.
And so Volta is a wonderful
GPU to be using from a training
perspective.
Is that also architected
for inference?
Or do you have other
options specifically?
And I know the answer.
But I wanted to give
you the chance to--
BRYAN CATANZARO: Yeah.
So let me explain a little
bit of the difference
between training
and inference first.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That would be great.
BRYAN CATANZARO: Training
is a search, like I said.
You're trying to find a model.
So the model may have hundreds
of millions or billions
of parameters.
And you need to fine
tune every one of those
to find the right number.
And so it's a search.
And you're searching for
it guided by your data.
And so we often talk
about back propagation.
What that means is you
do forward propagation,
where you use the model
to make a guess about what
the output should be-- say, if
we're doing speech recognition,
and the input is a wave
file, and the output is text.
So we run a bunch of
WAV files through,
and we get the guesses for
what those WAV files contain.
But then we know what the
right answer should be.
We have what's called labels.
We can use those labels to
figure out what the error was,
where was the model wrong.
And then we use that
to update the weights,
just tweak them,
just a little bit.
And we do that a million
times, or a billion times.
And so through this process,
it's kind of evolutionarily.
We search through this
space to find a good model.
So that's the training process.
The serving process, or
inference process, that's
just performing the
forward propagation.
Or given an input, what is
the output of that model.
So we're just pushing the data
forward through the model.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Just the prediction,
or the classification.
BRYAN CATANZARO:
Just the prediction,
or the classification.
So that computationally
is simpler,
because it's only
doing the forward pass.
It's not doing
the backward pass.
And not doing the learning.
But it has different
characteristics,
algorithmically.
And so it makes sense to have
software and hardware that
is tailored for both of
them in different ways.
And so it turns out
Volta is actually
a great GPU for inference.
I'm actually very excited about
using Voltas for inference.
The biggest problem, I
think, right now with Voltas
is that there's just not
enough Voltas in the world.
And all the Voltas
that we make get
sucked up to go into training,
because people need that
so much.
Whereas, inference
workloads are often smaller,
and so people can get by
with smaller processors.
But I do believe, in
the future, that we're
going to see big
inference workloads that
require even a Volta to deploy.
So I am excited about both
training and inference
for Volta.
But NVIDIA also has other
products specifically designed
for the inference market.
For example, the Tesla
P4, it's a small--
I think it's 50 to 75-watt--
GPU.
And it has some low-precision
arithmetic instructions.
Because in inference, you
don't need nearly as many bits
in order to get a good result
as you do during training.
And so the Tesla P4
is a really good ops
per second per watt processor
for the inference market.
MARK MANDEL: You said
something interesting
just before, where you were
talking about with the newer
GPUs, you were able
to do things you
weren't possibly able
to do before, possibly
inspirationally.
What are the things that you're
able to do now that you weren't
actually able to do before?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Well, I'll
speak a little bit to graphics,
because we're really excited
about that at NVIDIA.
But recently, there's been some
incredible generative models
for graphics that we've seen,
including the progressive GAN,
which generates very
high-resolution,
very high-quality images.
They trained it on the
celeb face data set.
And the faces that
it generates are
pretty indistinguishable
from real pictures of people,
even though they're completely
invented by this model.
And I think the leap
in fidelity for GANs,
when you are able to train them
on larger data sets for longer
periods of time,
is quite incredible
and changes the
kinds of applications
you can do with GANs.
The paper that I mentioned
that we've been working on
about synthesizing
photorealistic images
from semantic labels,
that work also, I think,
is pretty surprising.
I often look at the
output of that model,
and it takes me quite
a long time to figure
out is this a fake image
or is this a real image.
And that just would
not have been possible
without this processing power.
MELANIE WARRICK:
When I first met you,
you were doing a presentation
on parallelizing data for models
versus paralyzing a model.
And there's different
methodologies
in terms of how
do you split out--
especially if
you're trying to do
mass processing of a
deep learning model
in particular-- how
do you break that out
if you wanted to try to
do distributed computing.
What are your thoughts now in
terms of distributed computing
for deep learning?
Do you see that is
really a thing to do?
Or do you see just making
these chips better?
BRYAN CATANZARO: We need both.
So the great thing about
making the chip better
is that it plugs into
the software environment
without disruption.
Or the disruption is much less.
And so that allows
people to smoothly move
from one generation to the
next and get performance
improvements without having to
do big changes to their code.
And it also-- there's an
accessibility argument,
as well.
A lot of people
doing AI research
are operating on
a smaller scale.
And so if we can make the
small-scale processing better
and better, then that really
helps accessibility and sort
of democratizing
this technology.
And then, for people that
have the resources to use more
processors to train
a model, then being
able to have the software scale
to using many GPUs to train
one model provides really
compelling benefits.
And so we need that, as well.
And we focus on both
those things at NVIDIA.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
You've mentioned a number
of different groups,
in terms of their
work, and what's
going on out there in
the deep learning space
and in machine learning.
How much are you collaborating
with other outside groups?
How do you collaborate with
OpenAI, Facebook, Google?
BRYAN CATANZARO:
NVIDIA collaborates
with pretty much everyone.
I think we work pretty
hard on our relationships
with research labs, and academic
labs, and industrial labs.
The way we collaborate,
we like to basically help
people solve problems.
So people often
come to us and say,
we're having problems
getting good efficiency
with this particular model.
Can you help us?
And we'll look into
it and realize, oh,
cuDNN is choosing the
wrong implementation
for this particular convolution,
in this particular case.
So we can change the heuristic
and make that more efficient.
Or we can maybe add
a new implementation
for one of those
primitives that turns out
can be a lot better fitted
to the architecture.
And so we're constantly
iterating with researchers
from all over the world
about what their needs are
and how we can make
our products better.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are you
most excited about in terms of
where things are going with
AI and machine learning?
BRYAN CATANZARO: I'm really
excited about applications.
That's what I'm
doing for a living.
I feel like there are just
so many new ways of applying
this technology to pretty much
every field inside the world
economy.
We talk a lot about
self-driving cars.
And I'm very excited
about self-driving cars.
I think self-driving cars are
one of the applications that
are kind of on the vanguard
of really changing the world.
I'm really excited
about never having
to find a parking spot again.
And building houses where
all those parking lots are,
that would be really great
here in the Bay Area,
where there's not enough space.
So I think everybody is excited
about self-driving cars,
but I think that's
just the beginning.
I think every industry, from
agriculture to education
to art, there's just going to
be an explosion of applications
of AI.
And it's exciting to
be a part of that.
MELANIE WARRICK: And for
those who are starting out
wanting to get into, I mean,
even just doing chip design,
or trying to get into parallel
processing and deep learning,
do you have any recommendations,
or any things that you'd say
spend some time working
on, or some resources that
come to mind?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Yeah.
Well, let's see.
There's a couple of things
on my mind right now.
One of them-- so, I saw Google
put out a class recently,
sort of an introduction
to machine learning.
I looked through that briefly.
It looked pretty good.
So that seems like an
interesting thing to look at.
NVIDIA also has something called
the Deep Learning Institute,
where we give tutorials to help
people get hands-on experience
training models and using
deep learning frameworks.
I think that has been pretty
interesting for some people.
I'm also a fan of some of these
online education programs.
For example, I
work with Udacity.
Udacity has some great
nanodegrees in AI
that I think people
can get a lot of value
from going through.
And then, I guess, the two other
things that also come to mind
are open source-- so, there's
just so much out there.
If you search on the
open source, on GitHub,
you can find implementations
of all sorts of really
amazing deep learning models.
And you can download
them for free
and just start playing
around with them.
You don't even need to build
a machine that has a GP unit.
You can use a cloud service,
like the Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Nice.
Thank you.
BRYAN CATANZARO: And you
can get started really easy.
You don't have to invest
a whole bunch to jump in.
And then, I guess,
the last thing
that I wanted to mention, also--
I feel like I'm advertising
for Google here,
but it is actually a really
good thing-- is Kaggle.
So Kaggle is this
online competition,
where people can try to
solve real problems using AI.
And as somebody that's always
looking for talent to come
help us apply AI
to new problems,
when I see a resume
with somebody that's
been competitive in Kaggle,
I feel like, wow, this
is a person who is excited about
jumping in to solve problems
and is very hands-on.
And I think Kaggle
is a great way
to learn practical
skills about applying AI.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Also, one question before
we end up wrapping up.
As someone who's been
involved, especially
on the computational side of
things, for such a long period
and seen the history, I'm
curious to hear about what's
been the most surprising
thing for you,
or the most
surprising application
you've seen come out of
this stuff, or maybe even
the most interesting,
or weird, or wacky.
BRYAN CATANZARO: Well, one of
the most surprising, and weird,
and wacky papers
that I saw recently
was this one called
the "Deep Image Prior."
Basically what they're
doing is, instead
of training a deep learning
model on like a million images,
they train a deep learning
model on one image.
And this is a super crazy idea.
But the results are
actually kind of compelling,
that they're able to do some
tasks like image completion.
Imagine that you have a part
of the image that's damaged,
and you want to repair it.
They're able to
fill in that image
by training a deep
learning model just
on that very single
image, all by itself.
I thought that was pretty crazy.
I think there's a ton of
interesting applications
in agriculture.
I remember this blog post
from Google, actually,
about the cucumber sorting.
Do you guys remember that?
I think that was really--
MELANIE WARRICK: One of
our colleagues put that one
together, actually.
BRYAN CATANZARO: I
love that blog post.
I always reference it.
Because it was very
surprising to me that--
I don't know too many
cucumber farmers.
So my image of them is
maybe a little wrong.
But I just wouldn't
imagine a cucumber farmer
picking up TensorFlow
and training a model
to solve a problem that
they had on their farm.
And I thought that
was really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
That was definitely a fun one.
Well, as Mark was
mentioning, I know
we're getting short on time.
But was there
anything else that you
wanted to touch on or
cover before we let you go?
BRYAN CATANZARO: Yeah.
I guess one of the
things that I think
is really important in
the advancement of AI
is the software environment.
Maybe that's obvious to say.
But we still have a lot of
work to do to make it better.
And the environments
that we have now
represent a huge
amount of investment.
And I think sometimes we
take them for granted.
But I just wanted
to sort of highlight
that, as we progress
forward, there's
a lot of different ways of
increasing compute capacity
for deep learning, and for AI.
And I think that it's
important for all of us
to remember that it
has to sort of connect
all the way to the developers.
And the way that happens
is through the frameworks.
And so I wanted to kind of give
a shout-out to all the people
that are building TensorFlow,
and PyTorch, and all
the frameworks that people
use to train and deploy
these models.
Because I think that software
stack is incredibly important.
And it's changing rapidly.
And I think we're going to see
a lot of advancements there
that make deep
learning available
for even more applications.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, Bryan, thank you
again for joining us.
We really appreciate it.
BRYAN CATANZARO: Great.
It's been fun.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Well, thank you again, Bryan.
That was great to talk
to you about what's
going on at NVIDIA, and
what kind of research
your group is doing.
And as we mentioned
in the cool things,
we have the NVIDIA Tesla
V100s that are the world's
most advanced data center GPU.
That's going to be available
in the Google Cloud.
Now I think it's time for us to
dive into question of the week.
And so the question of
the week roughly is--
Sherol, Mark, you both
have been to GDC a lot.
And you know a lot about the
conference and the community.
So what can you tell us
as experts of the space?
MARK MANDEL: I think
Sherol should go first.
She's been going for
way longer than I have.
[LAUGHS]
SHEROL CHEN: I think at
some point in my computer
science undergrad, I was
like, the reason I'm in this
was to make video
games, ever since I was
five years old or something.
And I was like, where
do I go to find out?
So then I went to
my first GDC and was
amazed, because back then,
when I was an undergrad,
people were like, making games,
you can't do that for a living.
And then I found this huge event
with like tens of thousands
of people, where that's
what everybody did.
And I have been going
for 10 years to GDC.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And how long have you
been going for, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Like two
years, three years.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel like I'm still taking
baby steps, compared to Sherol.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
what's your favorite thing
about going to GDC?
SHEROL CHEN: I think this
is probably similar to Mark.
We both love games.
We love playing games.
We like the idea of that
creative space of making games.
We love new experiences
that come through games.
And GDC is where
you kind of find
the people that
are like us, people
who are out there creating
and innovating in this space.
And after a few
years, it just becomes
about connecting
with developers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I would I would echo that
100%, what Sherol said.
Definitely, it's the people.
The diversity of people and
the backgrounds that they have
is wonderful.
I meet so many people who
come from academic backgrounds
with a variety of
research, people
who come from
creative backgrounds,
from writing backgrounds,
from UX, from programming.
It is always a interesting
mix of ideas and people
coming together to produce some
often very interesting things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Granted, we're
releasing this on a Wednesday,
as always.
It's in the middle of
the week, in the middle
of the conference.
But what is some of the
activities that you're like,
you must go to this,
or you must check this
out when you go to GDC,
especially if you're
new to GDC?
SHEROL CHEN: So, for me, I
think one of the greatest
gateways to GDC is the parties.
It's great because--
after going once,
you immediately notice
that it's divided up
into communities, as well
as a whole gathering of game
developers.
And honestly, if
you're there, I think
the IGDA group, International
Game Developers Association,
is always putting out
events to kind of cultivate
a great community within
the developers in games.
And finding a community to
plug into is actually not hard.
You just have to--
it's just meeting
one friend, to the next
friend, to the next friend.
And eventually, you'll be
having to be triple-booked,
because you're part of so
many different communities.
MARK MANDEL: I'll tell
a little story, I guess,
since Sherol is here.
And I think it's hilarious.
So, the first year I went to
GDC, I was there for Google.
I staffed the booth, did that.
It was all fine.
We had a good time.
It was great.
Next year, Sherol joins Google.
And I was like--
SHEROL CHEN: We actually--
wait, wait, wait.
MARK MANDEL: --oh,
we're going to do GDC.
SHEROL CHEN: We actually
met at that booth, right?
MARK MANDEL: We did meet
at a booth that year.
SHEROL CHEN: We had met--
MARK MANDEL: It was
before you joined.
SHEROL CHEN: --right
before I joined.
I was at GDC.
And I decided, I
was like, oh, I'm
going to go work for Google.
I had already been
in that process.
I had met with the
hiring manager.
Things are looking good.
And then I was like, I'm going
to work on DevRel for Google.
And I got to meet Mark
for the first time.
I think that was the
first time we met.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
That is true.
Anyway, yeah.
So, second year that I go to
GDC, Sherol's on the team.
And I'm like,
we're going to GDC.
And she's like, cool.
I'm coming, too, and
doing stuff as well.
And she was like, but let
me show you how to GDC.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And it
was at that point
she introduced me to the
Fellowship of GDC Parties.
It's a group on Facebook.
Every year, they get together
and do this crowdsourcing
of all the parties at GDC.
She introduced me to all
the CAs that are all there,
the volunteers that run--
they're not volunteers,
actually.
They're employees that
run all of the events.
You see them wandering
around helping people out.
And yes, Sherol was amazing
in really sort of taking me
to that next level of GDC.
It's like she took
me under her wing
and really kind of
showed me the ropes.
MELANIE WARRICK: She
was your sage, your--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
She was my mentor.
MELANIE WARRICK: Your
mentor through the process.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's fantastic.
Well, that's great.
And anything else
you'd say, make
sure to plug for GDC for this
year, that you're like hey,
don't forget about?
MARK MANDEL: Always,
always, always,
always go to alt.ctrl.GDC.
That's the experimental area.
I love that place.
You always see some
of the weirdest stuff.
I think last year I saw a
game that involved people
having to blow into a box.
And that was your interaction.
And there was two
people on either side.
And it was just weird.
There was a lot of weird stuff.
But it's also wonderful when you
see some really creative stuff
there.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That sounds fun.
SHEROL CHEN: That also reminds
me of the experimental game
design challenge
that Robin Hunicke
does with a group of people.
And I think the experimental
stuff is definitely very cool,
because it's the most
forward-thinking of the stuff
that you'll see.
You also see really
cool postmortems
of some of the biggest hits of
the last year, which is really
interesting to dissect as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's fun.
So in terms of where people
will find you guys next,
where will people find you?
MARK MANDEL: So, at
GDC itself, we're
sponsoring the Women
in Games International
Party, which was yesterday.
So that doesn't help anybody.
On Wednesday itself, I
will be talking at 3:30.
There's a sponsor session we're
doing with Firebase and Google
Cloud.
So we're doing a little
what's new session, where
we're going to talk about
a bunch of stuff there.
Thursday, I will also be
talking at the Google booth,
doing a little talk on
[INAUDIBLE] at 12:30,
and then doing an Ask
the Expert session
after that for about
an hour as well.
Sherol, I know you're
up to a bunch of stuff.
What are you up to?
SHEROL CHEN: Actually, we're
in the middle of GDC right now.
There's been really amazing
events that have happened.
At Google, we sponsored Blacks
in Gaming awards ceremony
that happened yesterday.
Also, we're really happy to have
been sponsors of Serious Games
awards.
These are both IGDA events.
IGDA is an amazing
organization that
does a lot in the
community, of course.
My talk was actually yesterday.
I talked about machine
learning in games.
Just looking forward, I
mean, Wednesday's kind
of the big day.
This is where the majority
of the people show up.
So Wednesday, tonight, it's
going to be a lot of parties.
It's going to be a lot of
parties tomorrow night.
And I'll just be kind of
hanging out and catching up
with people, just kind
of-- a lot of this
is going to be lunches
with different groups
and different collaborators
that I've had in the past.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
you both were just
saying, before we started
recording, about how this year
it's very heavy
machine learning-based.
Is that right?
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know about heavy,
but I've definitely seen
that influence there.
I mean, there are
so many sessions
that are at GDC for
a variety of stuff.
But I'm seeing some roundtables.
I'm seeing a bunch of talks
about neural networks.
I think there's going to be a
definite crossover between AI
from a game sense and then AI
from a machine learning sense.
What do you take on that?
You definitely have much more
introspection into this area
than I do?
SHEROL CHEN: Well,
also, one of the things
that we're sponsoring is the
AI Game Developers Summit.
They have a reception.
So we're not sponsoring
the summit itself.
But yeah, it's interesting.
Because I think there's been
apprehensions of deep learning
in games, because in
games it's really easy
to create cognitive
dissonance in an experience.
It's interesting that now we're
in a day where deep learning's
effectiveness has gone up
by so much that we're trying
to figure out how to
leverage this technology
to create better, deeper,
more immersive games.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I
will ask one last question
for both of you.
Favorite game?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's easy.
So, for me, still, I put it out
to the "Mass Effect" series.
I'm just a huge fan
of that whole world.
Love the writing.
I love the direction.
I'm a just huge fan.
SHEROL CHEN: For
me, "Final Fantasy."
My Twitter handle is ffpaladin.
And "Final Fantasy" has just--
it's the game that made
me want to make games.
So it's got to be a favorite.
But I have to say, I've been
playing a lot of "Hearthstone."
That dungeon crawl is so good.
I don't know if you've played
it, Mark, but it's really good.
MARK MANDEL: Not
in while, actually.
I'm in the middle of
a big BioWare binge.
Talking about
"Mass Effect," I've
been playing "Dragon
Age Origins."
So I went--
SHEROL CHEN: Oh, my gosh.
MARK MANDEL: I've gone
back to the beginning.
I've gone back to the
beginning, and I'm just
going to play all the
way through all of it.
I don't know.
I'm just having so much fun.
SHEROL CHEN: I've been
wanting to play that series.
I've heard a lot of--
I haven't actually played
that many Western RPGs.
MARK MANDEL: It's good.
SHEROL CHEN: "Hearthstone,"
you have to try it out.
Just log in and do
the dungeon crawl.
It's excellent game
design, and really fun.
They did a really
good job with that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I will check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, cool.
Well, anything else you'd
both wanted to talk about in
regards to GDC that we
didn't already cover?
SHEROL CHEN: My
last advice is just
to just bring a lot
of business cards.
Because you end up
meeting so many people.
And you'll leave with a
huge stack of contacts.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
Thanks again, Sherol.
I'm so glad you were
able to join us.
And I'll do one
little last plug that
has nothing to do
with GDC, and instead
mention GTC, which is
NVIDIA's technology-- it's
their GPU Technology
Conference that's coming up.
And that's going
to be next week.
So just give a little
shout-out to that.
And then, Sherol, you
had one other thing?
SHEROL CHEN: The TensorFlow
Dev Summit, it's next week.
TensorFlow Dev
Summit is coming up.
And that's going to
have live stream talks.
And the talks will definitely
be there afterwards.
I'm actually speaking about
machine learning, research,
and creativity.
So definitely check
that out as well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thanks for covering it.
Anything else, Mark,
that we wanted to mention
before we close out this week?
MARK MANDEL: I plan on
sleeping a lot after GDC.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
no one can find you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm going to--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Don't look for you.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
taking some time off.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You're finally--
I'm going to GDC.
MARK MANDEL: I'm done.
MELANIE WARRICK: You are done
for the rest of the year.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie,
Sherol, thank you so
much for joining us for yet
another episode of the podcast.
SHEROL CHEN: Thanks
so much for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
SHEROL CHEN: Take care.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[ENERGETIC MUSIC]